what would happen if a star exploded
near the Earth
well the nearest star to Earth of course
is the sun and it is not going to
explode but if it had eight times the
mass then it would go supernova at the
end of its life so what would that look
like well as noted by xkcd if you held
up a hydrogen bomb right to your eyeball
and detonated it that explosion would
still be a billion times less bright
than watching the sun go supernova from
Earth
that's how insanely powerful Supernova
explosions are they are the biggest
explosions in the universe when we see
supernovae in other galaxies they are
brighter than the combined light of
hundreds of billions of stars so bright
in fact that they appear to come out of
nowhere
on the 8th of October 1604 the
astronomer Johannes Kepler looked up
into the night sky and noticed a bright
star he had never seen before it was
brighter than all the other stars in the
sky and about as bright as the planet
Jupiter on moonless nights it was bright
enough to cast a shadow
Kepler published his observations of
this star in a book called destella Nova
which means about a new star in Latin
Kepler thought he was witnessing the
birth of a new star but it was actually
a star's violent death
over the following year and a half the
light faded until it was no longer
visible
but the name stuck even once we learned
what was really happening in the 1930s
the violent final explosion for stars
between about 8 and 30 solar masses has
been called a supernova
but how exactly a star explodes is not
what most people think for most of a
star's life it exists in a stable
balance in its core it fuses lighter
elements together to make heavier ones
and in the process it converts a small
amount of matter into energy this energy
is really what keeps the star from
collapsing in on itself gravity
compresses the star but that force is
counteracted by the pressure generated
by the movement of particles inside the
star and by the pressure of photons
released by Fusion so in effect stars
are propped up by their own light
if the rate of fusion drops at the
center of the star the temperature and
the pressure decrease gravity starts
winning compressing the star but this
increases the temperature and pressure
in the core which increases the rate of
fusion it's a stable self-regulating
system
but there's a problem stars have a
finite amount of fuel which over time
gets used up
our sun is about 5 billion years into
its 10 billion year lifespan
there are stars dozens of times more
massive than the sun which you would
think would live much longer but they
actually use up their nuclear fuel
faster a star 20 times the mass of our
sun has a lifespan of just 10 million
years and more massive stars burn hotter
and even brighter but for much shorter
lives
for 90 the life of a star the core is
only hot enough to fuse hydrogen into
helium
and when the hydrogen Runs Out Fusion
slows gravity compresses the core and
its temperature increases to 200 million
degrees at which point helium fuses into
carbon there's enough helium to power
the star for around a million years but
as the helium runs out the core is again
compressed and heated carbon starts
fusing into neon which lasts about a
thousand years and then neon fuses into
oxygen for a few more years then oxygen
to Silicon for a few months and at 2.5
billion degrees silicon fuses into
nickel which decays into iron
now at the heart of this giant star
there is an iron core building that's
only a few thousand kilometers across
iron is where this pattern stops instead
of liberating energy as it fuses into
heavier elements it actually requires
energy
iron is the most stable element so it
actually takes energy both to fuse it
into heavier elements and to break it
down into lighter ones both fusion and
fission reactions ultimately end up at
iron
the iron core grows but the crush of
gravity becomes greater and greater as
the rate of fusion drops when the iron
core is about 1.4 times the mass of our
sun which is known as the chandrasekhar
limit the pull of gravity is so strong
that something totally wild happens
quantum mechanics takes over electrons
run out of room to move and they're
forced into their lowest energy states
they then become absorbed by the protons
in the nucleus
in this process the protons turn into
neutrons and release neutrinos
with the electrons gone the core
collapses and fast at about 25 percent
the speed of light so what used to be a
ball of iron 3000 kilometers in diameter
becomes a ball of neutrons just 30
kilometers across essentially it's a
neutron star
with no outward pressure to hold it up
the rest of the star caves in also
falling at a quarter the speed of light
it hits the neutron star and bounces off
creating a huge pressure wave but this
kinetic energy isn't quite enough to
start a supernova explosion now the
thing that really kicks it off is the
humble neutrino now I normally think of
neutrinos as particles that do basically
nothing I mean they interact so rarely
with matter that right now there are a
hundred trillion neutrinos passing
through your body per second it would
take a light year of lead just to give
you a 50 50 chance of stopping a
neutrino and that's because they
interact only through gravity and the
weak Force
but in a supernova when the electrons
are captured by the protons an
unbelievable number of neutrinos is
released around 10 to the 58 you would
think they would just fly off at nearly
the speed of light but the core of a
supernova is incredibly dense about 10
trillion times more dense than lead and
as a result it traps some of those
neutrinos and captures their energy and
this is what makes a star go supernova a
particle that is millions of times less
massive than an electron that barely
interacts with anything is responsible
for some of the largest explosions in
the universe
in that explosion only a hundredth of
one percent of the energy is released as
electromagnetic radiation the light that
we can see
even then Supernova have enough energy
to outshine a whole galaxy
about one percent of the energy is
released as the kinetic energy of the
exploding matter
but the vast majority of the energy is
released in the form of neutrinos
and neutrinos are actually the first
signal we detect from supernovae and
that's because after they're generated
in the core they can escape before the
shock wave reaches the surface where the
light that we see is generated so
neutrinos can arrive on Earth hours
before the photons giving astronomers a
chance to aim their telescopes at the
right part of the sky
[Music]
I actually used to work at a neutrino
Observatory back in college and I would
work the graveyard shift between
midnight and 8 am so if I detected a
really big increase in the neutrino flux
during my shift it was my job to call
and wake up scientists so they could go
look out for a supernova now that never
actually happened but we did have some
close calls now I need to clarify a
couple things first not all really
massive stars explode as they collapse
some form black holes instead which
means they do not go supernova and
second there's another way to make a
supernova sometimes a white dwarf star
which is incredibly dense pulls matter
off a nearby star and when its mass
reaches that Chandra secar limit of 1.4
solar masses the white dwarf collapses
creating a supernova this is actually
the type of supernova that Kepler saw in
1604 a supernova 20 000 light years from
Earth
now because the shocks are asymmetric
Supernova explain neutron stars that can
move really fast there's a neutron star
we've observed with a velocity of 1 600
kilometers per second
and we think that was caused by a very
asymmetric Supernova explosion sent it
shooting off in the other direction
despite only recently learning about how
supernovae work humans have been
observing them for thousands of years
ancient Indian Chinese Arabic and
European astronomers all observed
supernovae but they are quite rare in a
galaxy like our Milky Way consisting of
a hundred billion stars there are only
about one or two supernovae per century
a particularly amazing example is the
Supernova of 1054 when the light of a
supernova 6500 light years away reached
the Earth and was recorded by Chinese
astronomers if we look to where that
Supernova was recorded we see the Crab
Nebula it is a giant remnant of
radioactive matter left behind by the
explosion in the thousand years since
the explosion The Remnant has grown to
11 light years in diameter
supernovas produce a lot of cosmic rays
cosmic rays are actually particles
mainly protons and helium nuclei and
they travel out at very very nearly the
speed of light they have a tremendous
amount of energy
so at what distance could a supernova
cause problems for life on Earth the
closest stars to us besides the Sun are
the three stars in Alpha Centauri they
are 4.4 light years away
but stars do move around and on average
a star gets within one light year of
Earth every 500 000 years so what would
happen if such a star went off
yeah so within a light year you're
easily within a danger distance from
just the kinetic energy so I think even
at that distance you're you're looking
at possibly blowing the atmosphere off
but we would also have other problems to
worry about supernovae create conditions
that are hot enough to fuse elements
heavier than iron in the months after
the explosion these elements undergo
radioactive decay producing gamma rays
and cosmic rays less than 0.1 percent of
the energy produced by a supernova is
emitted as gamma rays from these
radioactive decays but even this tiny
percentage can be dangerous at a few
light years from a supernova the
radiation could be deadly though most of
it would be blocked by our atmosphere
now the Earth is protected from solar
and Cosmic radiation by our atmosphere
and specifically by ozone molecules
three oxygen atoms bonded together but
high energy cosmic rays from Supernova
can come down and break apart nitrogen
molecules in the atmosphere and then
these bond with oxygen atoms which can
then break apart ozone and so we can
lose a lot of our ozone if there's too
many cosmic rays coming from Supernova
events and that can expose us to all
kinds of dangerous radiation coming in
from space we actually see an increase
in atmospheric NO3 concentrations
coinciding with Supernova explosions a
supernova within 30 light years is rare
only happening maybe once every one and
a half billion years or so but a recent
article suggests supernovae could be
lethal all the way out to 150 light
years away and so those would be much
more common we actually have evidence
for a supernova that went off 150 light
years from Earth 2.6 million years ago
it would have been seen by our early
human ancestors like Australopithecus
and we know this because there are
elements present on earth that could
only have been deposited by a recent
supernova
in sedimentary rocks at the bottom of
the Pacific Ocean scientists have found
traces of iron 60 in a layer that was
deposited 2.6 million years ago iron 60
is an isotope of iron with four more
neutrons than the most common type of
iron
60 is really hard to make our sun
doesn't make it nor is it produced
basically anywhere else in the solar
system iron 60 is made basically
exclusively in Supernova explosions and
iron 60 is radioactive it has a
half-life of 2.6 million years so every
2.6 million years half of the sample
decays into Cobalt 60. so all of the
iron 60 that was around during the
formation of the earth four and a half
billion years ago has definitely decayed
so the iron 60 that the scientists
measure is proof of a recent Supernova
scientists also measured Trace Amounts
of Manganese 53 in the same sediments
giving further Evidence supporting the
idea that recently there was an
explosion of a nearby supernova
the Supernova that happened 2.6 million
years ago wasn't catastrophic for our
ancestors but some researchers
hypothesized that it could be related to
the mass extinction which is seen at the
pliocene pleistocene boundary in the
fossil record around the same time
this Extinction wiped out around a third
of marine megafauna the idea is that the
cosmic rays from the Supernova hit
particles in our atmosphere creating
muons which are charged particles like
the electron only more than 200 times
heavier the muon flux for years after
the Supernova would have been 150 times
higher than normal and the bigger the
animal the larger the radiation dose it
would have received from these muons
which is why megafauna were so
disproportionately affected
and what's more the animals that lived
in shallower waters were more likely to
become extinct compared to the ones that
lived at depth where the water would
have protected them from muons a further
evidence for these recent nearby
supernovae comes from our place in the
Galaxy you know if you look in the space
between the stars in our galaxy on
average there are around a million
hydrogen atoms per cubic meter that may
sound like a lot but it's basically a
perfect vacuum but for hundreds of light
years in all directions around our solar
system you find there are a thousand
times fewer hydrogen atoms it's like
they've all been blown out somewhere and
our solar system is existing in this
Cosmic void inside a low density bubble
so that is evidence for maybe tens of
supernovae that would have blown all
this material outwards but there are
cosmic explosions that are even more
deadly than normal supernovae gamma-ray
bursts gamma-ray bursts were discovered
by the Vela satellites which were
looking for Soviet nuclear tests but on
the 2nd of July 1967 the satellites
detected a large burst of gamma rays
which were coming from space
there are two main sources of gamma-ray
bursts mergers of neutron stars and the
core collapses of gigantic Stars called
hypernovae
hypernovae are caused by stars that are
at least 30 solar masses and rapidly
spinning their collapse leads to an
explosion 10 times more powerful than a
regular Supernova and it leaves behind a
black hole
the gamma-ray bursts caused by
hypernovae Channel most of their energy
into beams which are just a few degrees
across
if there was a gamma-ray burst within 6
000 light years it would decrease the
ozone level enough that it could be
catastrophic to put this distance in
context a sphere with a radius of 6000
light years contains hundreds of
millions of stars
on October 9th 2022 astronomers detected
one of the most powerful gamma-ray
bursts ever measured it was powerful
enough to measurably affect how the
ionosphere bounces radio waves the
effect on the ionosphere was around the
same as a solar flare but this gamma ray
burst was located in a Galaxy two and a
half billion light years away
astronomers speculate that a gamma-ray
burst could have caused the late
ordovician mass extinction which wiped
out 85 percent of marine species 440
million years ago there is no direct
evidence but gamma-ray bursts are common
enough that it is estimated that there
has been a 50 chance that there was an
ozone removing extinction-causing grb in
the vicinity of Earth in the last 500
million years so if a supernova or a
gamma-ray burst were to go off near the
earth now that would be pretty
catastrophic
but in an ironic twist we kind of owe
our existence to these sorts of
explosions because 4.6 billion years ago
it was probably the shock wave from a
nearby Supernova which triggered the
collapse of a cloud of gas and dust that
gradually coalesce to form our solar
system so the Sun the Earth and all of
us wouldn't be here today without the
explosions of nearby Stars
figuring out how Supernova explode was
incredibly difficult it took a
combination of astrophysics particle
physics Computer Science and Mathematics
and if you want to develop a better
understanding of our universe then you
should check out the sponsor of this
video brilliant just go to brilliant.org
veritasium and you can get started for
free right now brilliant is an
Interactive Learning tool that uses a
Hands-On approach to teach you a wide
range of stem Concepts you know watching
a video can give you a good overview of
a topic but if you really want to have a
deep understanding you need to learn
interactively and test yourself from the
foundations up brilliant offers
simulations to manipulate and quizzes to
master any new subject there are
thousands of lessons to explore ranging
from the foundations of math to
cosmology and quantum mechanics and
there are new exclusive lessons released
every month brilliant is the best way to
learn something new every day and
there's no better time to start the
first 200 people to sign up at
brilliant.org veritasium get 20 off an
annual premium subscribe option so I
want to thank brilliant for supporting
veritasium and I want to thank you for
watching